we're told the following equation is
true for all real values of Y for which
the expression on the left is defined
and D is a polynomial expression and
they have this equation here what is D
alright
so essentially what they're saying is
they don't want us to somehow solve this
equation they're saying D is going to be
some type of a polynomial expression
they tell us that right over there D is
a polynomial expression and if we if we
figure out what D is this left-hand side
of the expression is going to evaluate
to 1 for all real values of Y for which
the expression is defined so let's talk
about how we would tackle that well the
first thing that pops into my mind if
I'm dividing by a fraction or a rational
expression that's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal so let's
let's just rewrite this on the left hand
side so this is xx Y squared minus 80
over d x times 4 oh let me do the
reciprocal you can be careful times the
reciprocal of this if I divide by
something the same thing as multiplying
by the reciprocal so let me just swap
the numerator denominator into
numerators and denominators numerator
and denominator alright Y to the 3rd
plus 9y squared all of that over 4y
squared minus 8y that's going to be
equal to 1 now let's see if we can
simplify all of this business on the
left hand side a little bit so let's see
over here I can divide both terms by xx
so let me factor out xx because I think
then it's going to end up being a
difference of squares so if i factor out
a 20 so this is going the same thing as
20 times y squared minus 4 and Y squared
minus 4 we can rewrite as y plus 2 times
y minus 2 it is a difference of squares
so let me write that y plus 2 times y
minus 2 all right this down here 4y
squared minus 8y well it looks like we
can factor out
for why and so this is going to be the
same thing as for Y times y minus 2 all
right so let me cross that out so this
is same thing as 4y times y minus 2 and
I already see this y minus 2 here and
this Y minus 2 here are going to cancel
out and let's see up here both the both
terms are divisible by Y squared so I
can rewrite this as I don't know if this
is actually going to be helpful because
it's kind of if you factor let me just
do it just in case so that's the same
thing as y squared times y squared times
y plus 9 all right and so we can rewrite
all of these things if we were to
multiply everything together we would
end up getting in the numerator would
get 20 times y plus 2 times y minus 2
times y squared times y plus 9 I'm just
multiplying all the numerators and
that's going to be over in the
denominator I would have whatever the
expression d is x 4y for y times y minus
2 and that's all going to be equal to 1
now let's think about it we can divide
we can we have Y minus 2 divided by Y
minus 2 so those cancel out let's see we
have a we can divide the numerator or
the denominator by Y so that would just
become 1 and then that would just become
Y to the first power and so what we'd be
left with what would we be left with in
the numerator is 20 times this Y times y
plus 2 times y plus 9 over over for d-4d
is equal to 1 now if we want to solve
for D well we could just multiply both
sides by D and 1 times e is going to be
a DS you're going to have D equals
something over here would be done so
let's do that D times that let's
multiply that times D let me be clear
what I'm doing here let me draw
little divider here to be to make it
clear that to make it clear that that's
happening on the other side of the page
all right so D times this those cancel
out and we're going to be left with 20 Y
times actually let me I can simplify to
even more 20 divided by 4 is 5 so the
numerator is now just 1 so we have 5
times y times y plus 2 times y plus 9 is
equal to D and we're done this is D this
is the polynomial whoops that is that is
the polynomial expression that we are
looking for if you were to substitute
this back in and then try to simplify it
well you would end up with all of this
over here and D would be this and so it
would all just cancel out and you would
be left with 1 for all real values Y for
which the expression on the left is
actually defined and you know we there
are there are some values of Y for which
the expression on the left is not
defined if Y is equal to 0 this
denominator is 0 and you're dividing by
0 well that's not defined and then when
you make it when you divide when you
multiply by the reciprocal if if this
were to become 0 then that wouldn't be
cool either and there's multiple ways to
make this equal to 0 Y could be equal to
2 negative 9 that would also make this
bottom zero so we could think about that
if we wanted to but they're not asking
us to do that they're saying for all of
the real values for y for it's the
expression is defined find the D that
makes all of this business equal to 1
and we just did that